[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna pareigis engine guten wünsche
ich ihnen ja es gibt wieder deutsches
gold bei der kanuslalom wm in augsburg
aber ein echter traum lauf von
olympiasiegerin ricarda funk im
kajak-einer das schauen wir uns gleich
an jetzt erst mal unsere weiteren themen
heute
klartext in der türkei für ihre offene
kritik an der regierung bekommt
außenministerin berbalk lob von der
opposition im land
brände dürre borkenkäfer für viele
deutsche wälder droht dies ein
katastrophales jahr zu werden
und blamage für leverkusen der
bundesligist fliegt in der ersten runde
des dfb-pokals raus und zwar gegen den
drittligisten sv elversberg
nachdem die bundes außenministerin zum
auftakt ihres türkei-besuchs mit ihrem
amtskollegen davutoglu aneinander
geraten war hat sich annalena baerbock
heute mit mehreren oppositionsparteien
getroffen die begrüßten box klare worte
gegenüber der türkischen regierung bei
gleich mehreren außenpolitischen themen
und der menschenrechtslage patricia
wiedemeier
es gehört zum pflichtprogramm eines
offiziellen besuchs in ankara
kranzniederlegung im mausoleum von kemal
atatürk den begründer der republik
türkei auch die deutsche außenministerin
folgt diesen geflogenheiten doch mehr
entgegenkommen gibt es heute nicht zu
laut zu hart war der toten gestern abend
bei ihrem gespräch und der gemeinsamen
pressekonferenz mit ihrem türkischen
amtskollegen baerbock wurde scharf
angegriffen da sie zu vollen athen
türkische ansprüche auf griechische
inseln verurteilt hatte seine boni
ablöse frau merkel war stets eine
aufrichtige vermittlerin deutsche
politik war ausgeglichen ich verlange
nicht dass sie unsere sicht übernehmen
aber wir erwarten von deutschland das
ist unparteiisch verbleibt
es ist ein neuer ein anderer stil der
woche nimmt sich auffallend viel zeit
für gespräche mit vertretern von
opposition und
nichtregierungsorganisationen diese
wiederum haben große erwartungen
deutschland ist der wichtiges land
welche rechte für die demokratie die
deutsch türkischen beziehungen sind so
viel mehr als die baustellen sind vor
allen dingen beziehungen die auf ein
miteinander von menschen basieren gerade
die zivilgesellschaftlichen austausche
das ist das herz unseres miteinander zur
türkischen regierung kein wort mehr zu
heftig war wohl der gestrige
schlagabtausch endlich rede mal jemand
klartext und gehe auf konfrontation wie
es übrigens der türkische außenminister
auch tun meinte die opposition annalena
baerbock weiß genau sie braucht die
türkei als partner in vielen fragen
dennoch widerspricht sie und kritisiert
sie auf offener bühne so wie es lange
kein deutscher außenminister mehr getan
hat drei tage zwei länder es war keine
einfache reise für die deutsche
außenministerin
wer ist für den raketenangriff auf das
gefängnis im ostukrainischen donezk
verantwortlich russland und die ukraine
geben sich weiter gegenseitig die schuld
das russische verteidigungsministerium
veröffentlichte heute die namen von 50
getöteten und 73 verletzten gefangenen
der ukrainische präsident silencing
spricht von einem vorsätzlichen
russischen kriegsverbrechen das
internationale rote kreuz verlangt
zugang zum bombardierten gefängnis achse
konrad berichtet
sie klagen russland an und demonstrieren
für ihre helden viele hier in kiew
hatten angehörige in dem gefängnis in
alaska und sie wissen nicht ob sie noch
am leben sind wer aber schuld ist an den
über 50 toten ukrainischen gefangenen
ist für sie klar
am ort des geschehens sie noch kein
besetzten denn jetzt erzählen die
separatisten eine andere version sie
präsentieren geschützt teile angeblich
amerikanischer bauart
nachdem die gefangenen über ukrainische
kriegsverbrechen ausgepackt hatten die
von kiew angeordnet waren entschied die
regierung der ukraine den beschuss des
lagers mit einem amerikanischen mehrfach
raketenwerfer
der ukrainische geheimdienst dagegen
geht von einer sprengung des gebäudes
durch russische kräfte aus man habe die
misshandlung von gefangenen vertuschen
wollen
es war ein russisches kriegsverbrechen
ein absichtlicher massenmord an
ukrainischen kriegsgefangenen die
vorwürfe der beiden kriegsparteien
konnten bislang nicht von unabhängiger
seite überprüft werden
der krieg tobt derzeit in vielen
landesteilen es brennt ein weizenfeld
bhf ganz im norden kein zufall kein
unfall sondern offenbar nach gezielten
beschuss
es ist erntezeit da feuern sie ganz
bewusst auf uns und unsere ausrüstung
gut 200 km südlich bei sap arena wird
der mähdrescher nur mit schusssicherer
weste gefahren der helm griffbereit mit
raketeneinschlag rechnen sie hier
jederzeit es wäre nicht das erste mal
wir müssen doch das land am laufen
halten wir müssen für nahrung sorgen wir
müssen sehen und ernten zum ersten mal
in unserem leben unter diesen
bedingungen
ein lkw nach dem anderen fährt auf den
hof und dabei ist noch nicht mal die
ernte vom vergangenen jahr verschifft
in den hafen von odessa liegen doch
immer mindestens 16 frachter voll
beladen abfahrbereit und wissen nicht
wann sie ablegen können und vororten
odessa ist für uns eine brühl eine bei
ihnen warten ja die menschen seit
gestern darauf dass die schiffe endlich
auslaufen können wie gehen sie damit um
wir sind in den letzten tagen viel
durchs land gefahren und wirklich
überall sieht man diese riesigen
abgeernteten getreidefeldern und jeder
wirklich jeder erzählt einem das muss
eigentlich sofort losgehen mit diesen
schiffsladungen wir haben einen landwirt
getroffen der hat 15.000 tonnen neue
ernte in säcken bei sich auf dem hof
gelagert er sagt normalerweise bringt er
seine ernte immer direkt in den hafen
das ist nur zwei kilometer entfernt von
ihm er wie so viele andere glaubt dass
russland für diese verzögerung
verantwortlich ist die situation hier in
odessa ist insgesamt durchaus angespannt
es hat ja immer wieder angriffe mit
raketen auf die stadt und den hafen
gegeben es gibt sehr viele checkpoints
da wird trat kontrolliert besonders
entlang der küstenlinie und die sorge
hier ist schon groß dass russland diese
vermeintliche einigung in diesem
getreide deal dazu nutzt neue
militäraktionen vorzubereiten eindrücke
aus odessa dankeschön eine brille
innerhalb von zwei tagen im september
1942 erschossen deutschen
nationalsozialisten und ihre helfer in
babij jar einer schlucht auf dem
heutigen gebiet der ukrainischen
hauptstadt kiew über 33.000 jüdinnen und
juden die massenerschießung waren das
größte einzel massaker im zweiten
weltkrieg auf europäischem boden dort
wurde während der ganzen besatzungszeit
von den deutschen als exekution stelle
genutzt auch tausende sinti und roma
wurden hier ermordet heute besuchte der
antiziganismus beauftragte der
bundesregierung deimer güler die
gedenkstätte er legte blumen nieder und
gedachte der toten
in den irak dort sind anhänger des
einflussreichen schiitischen geistlichen
muktada al sadr in das irakische
parlament eingedrungen zum zweiten mal
in dieser woche in dem machtkampf will
die bewegung verhindern dass ihre
politischen gegner eine regierung bilden
können
demonstrierende rissen vor der stark
gesicherten grünen zone barrikaden ein
dort befinden sich viele
regierungsgebäude und ausländische
botschaften
mindestens 60 menschen wurden verletzt
nach einer sechstägigen kanada reise hat
der gesundheitlich angeschlagene papst
erstmals gerüchte um einen möglichen
rücktritt kommentiert franziskus sagte
prinzipiell sei es so wirklich kein
problem einen papst auszutauschen über
einen rücktritt denke aber noch nicht
nach sagte der papst vor journalistinnen
auf dem rückflug den tod von 4.000 bis
6.000 indigenen kindern und jugendlichen
in kanada bezeichnete er zum ersten mal
als völkermord
insgesamt waren bis 1996 rund 150.000
jungen und mädchen in schulen der
katholischen kirche von ihren familien
getrennt und ihre kultur beraubt worden
viele von ihnen wurden körperlich und
sexuell misshandelt
soldat oder soldatin werden in 20
ausbildungstagen geht nicht reservist
werden dagegen schon was erstmal
ungewöhnlich klingt findet immer mehr
resonanz der reservistenverband spürt
ein gestiegenes interesse von menschen
die sich ausbilden lassen wollen
anschließen möchten sie in einer
kompanie denen etwa bei
katastrophenlagen oder als verstärkung
im wachdienst von militärischen
einrichtungen christa haas berichtet
das ist keine normale wehrübung die die
hier in ihre stellungen robben sind
zivilisten und deutlich über 18 jetzt
wollen sie reservisten werden zb sabrina
und massimo sie ist eigentlich
kaufmännische angestellte der prozess
techniker ihre aufgabe das lager für die
nacht aufbauen stellungen ausüben und
turner wir wollten einfach mal in das
berufsleben eines soldaten rein schauen
was sie so leisten wenn katastrophen
sind dass wir einspringen können damit
wir wissen was wir zu tun haben wenn es
zur verteidigung des landes ist die
bundeswehr braucht mehr reservisten für
den heimatschutz seit die wehrpflicht
abgeschafft wurde seit vier jahren gibt
es deshalb auch eine ausbildung für
unbediente
zwei mal zehn tage schießtraining mit
scharfer munition inklusive wir sind
hier nicht im dschungelcamp wir sind
hier bei der bundeswehr und da gehörten
harte und fordernde ausbildung dazu
seitdem ukraine konflikt ist ja das
thema bundeswehr sowohl in der
gesellschaft wie auch in der politik
eigentlich immer wegzudenken bis jetzt
sind bundesweit 590 zivilisten
ausgebildet worden im nächsten jahr
sollen noch einmal 500 dazu kommen das
interesse sei da sagt die bundeswehr
vom zivilist zum reservisten alle hier
haben dasselbe ziel etwas tun für irland
und gleichzeitig hoffen sie dass sie nie
im ernstfall zur waffe greifen müssen
das feuer im brandenburgischen
elbe-elster-kreis hat sich nach
offiziellen angaben entspannt im
nationalpark sächsische schweiz hingegen
geht der kampf gegen den verheerenden
waldbrand weiter 13 hubschrauber und 350
feuerwehrleute sind dort im einsatz
beiderseits der deutsch tschechischen
grenze werden immer wieder neue brände
entdeckt das feuer im
elbsandsteingebirge war am vergangenen
wochenende auf tschechischer seite
ausgebrochen
die waldbrände im osten machen auch
eines deutlich wie wenig es in den
vergangenen monaten geregnet hat fast
überall war es trockener als im
langjährigen durchschnitt in weiten
teilen deutschlands herrscht dürre auch
in tieferen bodenschichten
bäume reagieren besonders empfindlich
auf diese trockenheit und werden
anfälliger für schädlinge wie den
borkenkäfer der breitet sich immer
weiter aus florian korte war für uns in
den wäldern thüringens unterwegs vor
nicht mal einem monat stand hier noch
fichte an fichte dicht an dicht doch
dann kam der borkenkäfer und nistete
sich ein der baum stirbt raum ab weil im
prinzip diese lebende schicht zwischen
rinder im sprint holz das kambium im
prinzip komplett unterbrochen wird und
damit die wasserzufuhr in bar massiv
zusammenbricht den forstleuten bleibt
nur die fichten zu fällen und möglichst
schnell aus dem wald zu schaffen denn
die käfer vermehren sich rasant dann
heißt es einem einzigen käfer
150000 nachkommen entstehen können und
das ist ein so gewaltiger population
stroke der die benachbarten bremen
fliegt ja dass sie keine chance haben
sich zu und die sind zurzeit ohnehin
geschwächt weil ihre wurzeln kaum noch
an wasser kommen wie ines kamara in
einer messstation zeigt diese flasche
ist dafür da um auch boden wasser zu
sammeln wenn denn welches da ist es ist
aber kein wasser dar das heißt von der
bodenoberfläche bis in 1 meter gibt es
momentan kein pflanzen verfügbares
wasser in thüringen sind diesen sommer
nur 20 bis 30 prozent des üblichen
regens gefallen weniger als in allen
anderen bundesländern
auch wenn jetzt schauer und gewitter
kommen bringen die für die dürre gar
nichts was jetzt helfen würde wäre
langandauernder leichter dauerregen der
ist nicht in sicht so können die männer
und frauen vom forst weiterhin nur
versuchen die schäden so gering wie
möglich zu halten im kampf gegen einen
aktuell offenbar übermächtigen gegner
den borkenkäfer
eine seilbahnfahrt hinauf zum
niederwalddenkmal oberhalb von rüdesheim
mit blick auf den rhein wurde für 41
menschen gestern abend zu einem
erschreckenden ergebnis wegen eines
technischen defekts war die seilbahn
stehen geblieben mit drehleitern und
seilen wurden die fahrgäste aus bis zu
14 meter höhe von den rettungskräften
aus den gondeln befreit
nach etwa drei stunden hatten alle
wieder sicheren boden unter den füßen
seit diesem wochenende sind in ganz
deutschland sommerferien das merkt man
auch auf den autobahnen wie hier auf der
a1 bei bremen bildeten sich lange staus
bis morgen abend erwartet der adac eines
der schlimmsten stau wochenenden der
saison noch schlimmer ist die situation
in frankreich auf dem weg ans meer
stauten sich die autos landesweit auf
mehr als 800 kilometer
es ist ein eigentümliches spektakel das
sich jedes jahr zum geburtstag der
sängerin kate bush abspielt in vielen
parks rund um die welt tanzen tausende
menschen in roten kleidern das
musikvideo zum kulthit wetering und das
obwohl der song aus dem jahr 1978 stand
dank einer tv serie ist kate bush gerade
so angesagt wie selten sebastian kowski
hat sich rote flattr kostüme in berlin
angeschaut
ja ein bisschen verrückt ist es schon
was sich heute im berliner görlitzer
park abspielte nämlich verrückt nach
kate bush etwa 300 enthusiastische
tänzerinnen und tänzer führen noch
einmal das musikvideo zum kulthit
weiteren highlights von
1978 nach ausdruckstanz trifft auf
mysteriöse texte was so mittlerweile in
über 40 städten weltweit regelrecht
zelebriert wird
sie sehen eine freude auf die geschichte
dass das wäre alles alle kinder alle
aller alte zusammen kommen und zusammen
mit kanzlerin bisschen freude mitnehmen
das ist alles
dabei erlebt die musik von kate bush
momentan ein absolutes revival auslöser
dafür war aber ein anderes lied von ihr
running up that hill dass durch die
netflix serie stranger sings 37 jahre
nach veröffentlichung weltweit die
charts stürmt und damit auch ein
jüngeres publikum erreicht ich fühle
mich immer so verträgt wenn ich das höre
und hat irgendwie so eine gewisse magie
und es halt einfach gutes songs und
passt gut in die serie gepasst und kann
ich gut verstehen dass es dann so ein
hype ausgelöst habe
ein hype um kate bush der bei seiner
ganzen verrücktheit offensichtlich sehr
glücklich macht
zum fussball das macht ja auch viele
leute glücklich norbert und zum dfb
pokal der ja bekanntlich wirklich seine
eigenen gesetze schreiben ja ganz
berühmter spruch aber der gilt auch
heute wieder wenn hochfavorisierte
bundesligisten aus dem wettbewerb
fliegen zweitligist regensburg fliegt
köln im elfmeterschießen mit 4 2 3 ja
und drittligist elversberg bz leverkusen
in einem hochdramatischen spiel absolut
verdient mit 4 2
als der letzte leverkusener angriff in
den armen von elversberg torhüter
christoph endet ist eine große pokal
überraschung perfekt noch keine zwei
minuten sind gespielt als rocknet den
außenseiter in führung schießt zwar
reagiert leverkusen und gleich durch
neuzugang logic nur drei minuten später
aus doch nach toren zum 2 1 und 2 zu 2
sorgt schnellbacher für die elversberger
halbzeitführung in der 74 minute kam
kevin conrad auf vier zu zwei für
elversberg erhöhen der leverkusener
anschlusstreffer kommt zu spät und so
schlägt ein drittliga aufsteiger einen
champions league starter der pokal
macht's möglich
und hier die bisherigen ergebnisse der
ersten hauptrunde des dfb-pokals
elversberg gegen leverkusen wir gesehen
4 zu 3 ebenso regensburg können viktoria
berlin unter die bochum 0 zu 3 strahlen
verliert ganz knapp gegen st pauli mit
drei zu vier illertissen gegen
heidenheim nur zu zwei wernigerode
verliert zweistellig gegen paderborn 0
zu zehn bayreuth unterliegt dem hsv aber
erst in der verlängerung mit 1 2 3
lübeck in rostock 13 ja- und bereits
gestern unterlag 1860 münchen den bvb
mit 0 zu 3 knappe 0 1 niederlage für
dresden gegen bundesligist stuttgart und
eine klatsche für
neustrelitz 0 zu 8 gegen den ksc und
schließlich kam nach irgendwann verlor
gegen nürnberg mit 0 2 die dfb
pokalspiele später ausfindig bei uns im
aktuellen sportstudio um 23 uhr und
zusammenfassungen sie können sich schon
jetzt sehen auf zdf heute die und in der
zdf- heute- app ja und morgen 18 uhr
anstoß im wembley-stadion über 90.000
zuschauer das ist rekord kulisse für das
fußball em finale england gegen
deutschland das dfb team hoch motiviert
und zuversichtlich
endspiel im geschichtsträchtigen wembley
gegen die gastgeberinnen eine
konstellation die bundestrainerin
martina voss tecklenburg auf der
abschluss pressekonferenz ins schwärmen
versetzt ich weiß nicht ob es viele
größere sport momente für unsere
spielerinnen geben wird oder schon
gegeben hat es gehört sicherlich zu den
größten die kulisse bei einem em finale
wird jedenfalls so groß sein wie nie
zuvor ein auswärtsspiel bei dem clara
bühl nach ihrer corona erkrankung
definitiv nicht mithelfen kann doch mit
einer kapitänin alexandra popp in
bestform sechs tore in fünf spielen ist
ein weiterer großer sport moment möglich
der neuen europameisterschafts titel für
deutschlands fußball frauen
olympiasiegerin ricarda funk hat bei der
kanu slalom wm in augsburg gold im kajak
einer gewonnen die 30 jährige titel
verteidigen fuhr bereits im letzten kurs
drittel nahezu perfekt und sicherte sich
souverän den wm titel vor der
australierin jessica fox den deutschen
erfolg im eiskanal komplizierte elena
willig die bronze gewann
er bereits die zweite goldmedaille über
diese wm für ghana von dankeschön und
zumeist so ruhige sommerwetter
verspricht uns katja horneffer für
morgen und sagt uns auch gleich groß
denn noch schauer und gewitter geben
kann das heute journal an diesem abend
um 22 44 mit mit reserven auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend auch gestern gab es wieder
meistens nur wenige liter regen pro
quadratmeter punktuell aber durchaus
auch mal mehr als 50 liter pro
quadratmeter
jetzt in der nacht ziehen die letzten
regenschauer ostwärts aus deutschland
raus und die temperaturen sinken auf 17
grad ganz im westen und bis auf zehn
grad zum beispiel im oberpfälzer wald
die höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen
zwischen 21 grad auf den ostfriesischen
inseln und bis zu 32 grad am oberrhein
und das wird für die meisten ein
freundlicher sonntag sonne und wolken
wechseln sich ab nur im nordwesten da
gibt es kräftige regen schauer und auch
gewitter es wird einfach unbeständiger
und das zeigt sich dann noch anfang der
kommenden woche zur wochenmitte aber
steigen die temperaturen zum teil über
35 grad aber wie wir das in den
vergangenen wochen ja schon erlebt haben
hält dieser höhe hitze punkt nur ein
zwei tage durch schauen wir noch kurz
zurück auf den juli der war
deutschlandweit mit 19,2 grad 0,9 grad
wärmer als im vieljährigen
klimatologischen mittel der jahre 1991
bis 2020 er war 60% trockener und 17%
sonniger guten abend